[Music]
all right let's go to carmen in seattle
washington home of allison james what's
up carmen
hi how are you
i'm well how about yourself
well too well too hey
is the grunge scene coming back are we
going to do this again or no
man yes my 14 year old
no joke was wearing a flannel
high-waisted like mom
jeans they were the pipe jeans do you
remember those yeah dude pearl jam jeans
yes
yeah
it would ever go away i don't know not
the suicide part but the style part is
fine
like a true seattle light you took this
thing real dark real fast so well done
okay so okay hold on i'll never forget i
think it was i think it was like an
interview with vince neil or something
the lead singer volley crew one of those
and he said something along the lines of
everybody's life is terrible that's why
we sing about like parties and craziness
like because all of our lives are awful
so he's thinking about this and he's
like i don't understand why
everyone in seattle just wants to sing
about how bad everything is and i
thought yeah
yeah and then i talked to seattle light
today
and i was like yeah things are great
but that could get worse
way to go yeah dude oh that's so
interesting okay that's funny all right
so what's up how can i help
um
okay so
should we tell our teenage daughter that
her dad lost his faith and is now an
atheist oh okay tell me about it
what's the journey been like my
husband is a gift to me he's like every
answered prayer from my youth okay and i
had a hard childhood on a seven on the
asus scale or whatever hold on hold on
for a second
whoa
right
whose isn't i don't know
most seven is high
that's a hard hard childhood
not if you ask the parents
that's why
that's why in the aces scale or any sort
of trauma skill it's not
so what's your parents interpretation of
yeah that's not a question right um
how'd you meet this guy
stupid it's like i'm telling you it's
ridiculous
this guy was i was on the worship team
at church as a kid he's quite a bit
older than i am
and
he oh all like one day there was like
this new worship leader and i was like
okay that's weird
um well it turns out that this guy had
just come back from
a
training for
but it was like basically a two-year
mission where he went to get his
pastoral license
okay and
super devoted sort of an obnoxiously so
guy
but
then we
show him up oh gross all right i know
did he have did was he one of those
worship leaders that has like tight acid
wash sparkly jeans like with the
bejeweled jeans
please say yes that would never
ever
ever
he would never ever
hey that's all i needed to know good so
you married well all right good
cool so you you are like
singing background vocals in like the
church
yeah and y'all are just like repeating
the same line over and over and over
again like worship music does and you
look over there and you're all alone
and you see this guy and you're like
he's not wearing bejeweled pants i think
i think i'm in okay so it was so funny
actually it's this is so funny so
and we've been married for almost
almost 16 years 16 or 17 years i'm not
sure a long time and we're best friends
we have very good open communication
with each other
we make fun of each other every day
um
and also support each other ball anyway
so we have been married for like six
months
and
i was pregnant and it was really it was
kind of a
terminal truess
and crappy rocky
um yeah first start to the pregnancy
then our daughter was 11 months old and
we were driving to a birthday party on
like a saturday and i said you know we
were having some sort of
i don't know
mundane conversation
and i and he said something that
triggered
me to ask him
well
like
jesus christ is lord and savior and
we're all sinners
and he was like i don't i actually don't
think that
and i
my
my response to him i'm an eight on the
immunogram i don't know if you're into
that and uh you got lots of numbers
running your life good continue yeah
um
so he said
oh my response to him was um
well that's that's a lie you've said
you've said differently for the last you
know i've known you for
five years like that's not
at that point right
that doesn't sound
accurate
and
that was kind of like the pandora's box
gotcha
um so has it taken 16 years for that to
slowly
or is he just no so he told me that
within the first year of marriage okay
our daughter was 11 months old at the
time
now that 11 month old daughter
is you know 14 and three quarters
and she's wonderful
but he
he feels quite a bit of
cognitive dissonance about
his honesty level with the kids like
we've always kind of been big into we've
never been into santa like we don't i
just don't want to lie it's great to you
know have a santa on a christmas bag or
whatever but no actually grandma and
grandpa worked really hard and that's
where the gift came from
okay all right
um very seattle of you very aggressive
and
why have joy in sparkles when we can
have gray sadness i know
oh no
hey man i wore shorts and tights with
doc martens back in the day too we've
all been there right i've had a flannel
shirt around my waist as well
so i actually thought that like
birkenstocks and wool socks together was
like
a like a universally accepted thing it's
it's it's not it's actually it's in the
dsm it's a it's a
psychological disorder but that's a
whole other thing
all right so
in your home
you've got a wonderful guy you'll love
him he's your best friend
oh my gosh and he
he has um
journeyed away from his his faith or
he's just on a different different path
for but she's going to say that and
does he still no he's an atheist like
he's an atheist
but yeah yeah but does he still saddle
up and go to church with you all every
week are you still in part of your faith
community how are you raising your kids
how's that all working together
uh
well
i i deal in contracts for a living so i
holy smokes no and he was super on board
because he actually when
when it all kind of came out to his
family who is i always say like they're
like the real questions christians like
they fight in a healthy way you know
and um try to live by
being kind to people when that all came
out to the family he
was very
i would say heartbroken um because he
was like honestly i never wanted my
parents to know they're in their 80s
you know like i don't want to cause me
to stress his dad as a pastor was the
pastor of that church right so you so
let me get you made him tell his parents
no
okay
this or manipulated him into it
oh jeez
i know right so here this whole thing
like
so you may have heard me say this and i
got this from
dr bernie brown like
shame eats secrets for breakfast is the
way she says it
yeah i know and the more secrets a
family has the more dysfunction there it
is and the more pathology is there is
and then like you literally live less
long
like your body just eats itself right
and i've actually seen that
in real life like i saw this woman she
was a client i swear she died from
bitterness
45
yeah absolutely yes your body just says
i'm out they call it long tail suicide
like your body just begins to grind
itself to a halt it can't handle that
much stress those many stress hormones
but i'll also say this
we also
and
this is like towards answering your
question
we also when we have these epiphanies
these awakenings i do faith differently
than my parents did yeah i grew up with
parents who were very much
go find it on your own
very much so and we'll disagree and have
conversations but i i grew up with that
kind of support system so i get that but
it looks very different basically been
what we've done okay with our kids but
listen sometimes
when we have an epiphany about faith or
about covet or about relationships or
about whatever
we feel burdened by it and we feel like
we've got to announce it to everybody
you know the worst people are
crossfitters and diet people oh i
discovered this new gym it's and we just
proselytize everybody about your dumb
new gym or your weird diet
congratulations i'm glad this works for
you i i'm not in the tupperware or
essential oils or whatever the thing is
yeah and so we feel like we got to tell
everybody and it's not about them it's
about us
yes and we have to be okay and when
somebody feels like i'm gonna go tell my
80 year old parents
yes i'm gonna break their hearts so i
can get this so i can live authentic
shut up
thank you
and this isn't even yours kristen like
i love you like getting after your
sister
so
you know what i mean it's it's both hand
yeah if my dad of 80 asked me hey how's
your faith be like hey man it's been 80
is very different than 14 you know what
your passion for his
yes like struggle with this because we i
you know i it's starting to feel like
we're being dishonest yeah technically
we never lied to you no no yeah like
we're being dishonest yes so we're not
so does he like so just brass tacks does
he get up and
put on his non-sparkly jeans every
sunday and does he still lead worship at
a church does he
does he go with you all every week and
sing along and play along and does he do
that with y'all every week
so he has not led worship in
that actually so okay all this came out
on a saturday that next day sunday was
his last day of lean worship so he
hasn't led worship in 14 and a half
years something like that so he's a man
he's a man of integrity
he's a man of integrity like we joined
trail life i don't know if you know what
that is but it's a no idea it's a
christ-centered scouting group for young
men and then there's a woman's one and
jesus in the woods baby yeah right
and he
did not
it wasn't even a question on whether or
not he was going to sign that statement
of faith gotcha you know so they
actually ended up writing they know us
because they know him he did a
background check on him all the things
they know us
but
you know he's not willing he's not going
to sign something that says
he's
to prove he has character would mean he
didn't have character exactly exactly
no so so
so here's the thing with my daughter it
seems like if we told her and we've
gotten mixed counsel on this so it seems
to me that if we were to tell her and
then there's a 12 year old coming up
right behind her
that did all these things
then they're gonna it would be like us
putting like their our brick in their
backpack i don't feel that this is
something we're not even completely
so here's the brick that you're putting
in their backpack
the brick you're putting in their
backpack is they absorb the cognitive
dissonance
yeah they breathe
and they think at some level it's them
so
okay another little twist he actually my
husband
my husband knows biblical like he knows
the bible he has like a couple different
you know
like the latin yada yada
and so
you know we'll be having a discussion
and he's able to contribute
and
he's he's performing and he's but
and that's sort of how yeah and he's the
last right and so he that was how he got
attention whatever well
here's the deal
i think a
honest conversation with your 14 year
old is fair
in a
non-non-dumping his stuff onto her
because here's where it sounds like do
you tell me if i'm wrong
i'll go to task with anybody has a
church hurt a bajillion people yep oh
and yeah
do they continue to
take care of people all across the world
absolutely
yeah and so he sounds like a guy
who has
lost the sensational parts of the story
the hard parts of the story but has kept
the practice
is still a person of character and
dignity does that make sense yes
yes train a child and the way they
should go and they will not depart from
it when they're older and i'm like it
doesn't say that they're gonna be saved
well so listen
i think it is he is gonna be able to
have this conversation without burning
the whole thing to the ground
for sure oh dang it dang it and he's on
the wrong side
oh are y'all competing
no i'm always competing everything is a
competition dude i'm just a dude on the
on that podcast yeah take my my this
advice is free right yes
um yeah you're getting what you pay for
here but listen
okay here's where uh i'm and i'm gonna
i'm gonna
come after you in a second are you ready
yeah well let me do this so
i think it's worth a conversation of
truth to say hey
i believe in these principles i believe
in the
like here i'm not going to put words in
his mouth here's what i do
and here's where the last
15 years
i've been been on a path and here's
where i am right now
yeah and i will tell you i had s long
seasons of of being a full-blown atheist
i believe none of this nonsense
of my particular faith none of it
thought it was insane
higher education's fault i'm just
kidding
it's super not um i know but
um then i had a set of experiences
being with people who'd lost people in
the middle like dealing with some dark
dark trauma
yeah and
it i got a different picture and a new
picture so what i would tell you is who
knows what two years from now looks like
in five years and ten years from now
looks like yeah who knows what i would
tell you is i think being honest about
the path with his daughter is important
because then she goes oh and if he says
this is hard
and i loved the comfort of like being
honest about his path
hiding that journey from your daughter
is
she's just gonna internalize it
because she know she doesn't know that
dad's on contract with mom but she knows
you know what i
mean it i never thought of it that way
she does
every morning from the way he
huffs the way he doesn't quite you know
he sits quietly in the back he doesn't
pick up the but he knows no
fool plays worship music and family
gatherings when we ask him to okay
when we ask him to and there will come a
moment when she's like man every time
you get in the car you put on motley
crue what you know i mean she'll ask
those questions
she'll know just like kelly's kids ask
those questions right i'm just kidding
do i force my husband to perform
yes and there's gonna that didn't that
that dissonance is all is is becoming
expressed in your kid's dna
all right see how much he loves me he's
so great
okay and so here here's what's
here's what i don't think has happened
um i don't think you've made peace yet
no you no absolutely not carmen you're
hanging on to a fantasy you're hanging
on to a mix
of fantasy so we agreed to before we got
married
but you are trying to duct tape together
a picture of a family that all goes to
church together and all
does the little whatever i don't even
know it goes to
trailblazer jesus jesus in the woods
together we all do all these things
together and you you you trying so hard
to keep this picture together he's on
contract
he's on contract right you are so
invested in this picture and it's not
real
and you've got to exhale
i am married to
and i love
an extraordinary man
who also
fill in the blame
and i don't think you've made peace with
that yet
that part of him
right and that's a part of him
yeah
it's both and
and when you make peace with that
and you show your daughter
yeah as i this isn't the guy married but
he changed and yeah he's still
a guy who shows up and he's still a
person a character and i still love him
and he still loves you this is what
fidelity looks like this is what
marriage looks like you want to talk
about giving her gifts
you talk about her not picking up bricks
she's she knows what love looks like
you know what i mean
and right now by not having that
conversation you're you're
you're you're taking that opportunity
from her so it's an incredible i think
it's by poe bronson um it's been a
couple years since i read it's called
nurture shock one of the things i
remember from that book uh that is years
ago and we'll link to it in the show
notes it's uh what i remember was it was
a phenomenal book i remember closing it
going whoa
but he says that
a lot of parents our generation of
parents were told don't fight in front
of the kids
if you have disagreements in front of
the kids you're going to freak them out
you're going to scare them and you're
going to think their world's coming
apart yeah and so what parents did was
they went in the back bedroom and fought
and then they came out a united front or
whatever somebody won somebody lost
whatever or a very united front that was
a silent front how about that
and what bronson points out is we stole
from our children
a picture of how two people love each
other and disagree and then still make
dinner together
right and now we have a world where if
we have a disagreement we think oh
that's it we're out of love and then we
break up and move on
or we go post crap about each other or
we can't get it i mean i think this has
rippled through our culture politically
dietary through everything
and so by saying yeah me and your dad
man
it made me sad
because i still believe in my faith with
all of my heart
and
but we do have we do believe in
principles and she'll ask natural
questions like
well what if dad decides he doesn't love
me
and those are hard i know but those are
hard things that a 14 year old asks what
is that because yeah yeah what if he
decides he doesn't love you
then your daughter gets a ringside seat
to love is a risk
and then he gets to look at her i'd say
i will never
leave you
yeah you know what i mean and so these
are hard
these are real and they are gritty
but i i will always go to a foundation
financial intent of my life is
never lie to your kids and right now
y'all are lying to your kids
um
lying she's not telling the whole truth
yes that's true right and i say that i'm
being direct with you but we're you're
my friend
um
show her that you and your husband are
still connected and married yeah and in
love and you have different faiths
one faith no faith
let her
know that cognitive dissonance is y'alls
not hers right
and she may ask questions and say yeah
this is where i land and not hers so
instead of okay so the way i've been
thinking about it is like we're putting
our brick in her backpack
but really it's it's you know taking
that brick out of her backpack and
saying identifying it and saying this is
what it is
you know you probably have felt things
yeah
do you have any questions yep or she
might say how could dad have played the
charade for so long she feels betrayed
absolutely she should feel betrayed heck
yeah you know what i mean and not in a
no no no
she should feel betrayed and that's okay
because you're saying like you can't fix
the last 14 years you can just go
forward now
right yeah
and i still think it's good for
um
i think the data plays out go to church
they even have atheist church popping up
people get there and sing together and
they show up once a week and they it's
almost like uh how to do community the
the practice is important it's been
going on for thousands of years so i
still think he goes to church with you
if he was on the phone i was talking to
him i'd say dude i think you still go i
think you still there's
high
high value i think you still give i
think you still serve i think you still
participate
i really really do
i feel strongly about that what kept me
alive as a person was in my seasons of
doubt i kept going i kept going
and some of it was just to keep the
peace in my home some of it was i had a
job where at like a faith-based
organization i had to you know i mean
but you just keep going and you keep
going just like there are seasons when i
don't want to work out and you just get
up and do it anyway and there's seasons
when man one more drink would be awesome
and you don't or a donut would be
awesome and you don't you don't
i mean sometimes donuts are so cute fine
yeah but but listen listen now you got
me thinking about donuts and
that happens to talk
but i think you keep going with the
practice because the practice is right
practice is good
and i would
really encourage you to sit down because
you you haven't come to terms with this
yet for four years
i was a child i was 18 years old yeah
yeah yeah you know how much frontal lobe
development have you had at 21. it's
like you know what i mean
yeah yeah but here we are so we can't go
backwards we can only go forwards
and i was well and i don't think it's
going to be appropriate for her to tell
to tell her brothers this is not a
stance you know
absolutely you know this is and we
actually have a phrase in our families
it's like this is family business that
means you don't talk about it with
anybody but us
well right yes but you got to be careful
about that because i know it turns into
a
yeah that gets gnarly right right it's
like keeping a secret that's true that's
right and so i i don't want
yeah just be careful with that type of
language but you can't let them know
this is dad talking privately and i'm
going to ask you to not um not tell
people oh that's a good phrase but this
is my story and i want to share my story
with you
and my story is not your story
and your mommy you though do i share my
story with her absolutely yes
absolutely yes now the details of all
seven aces probably not right but she's
gonna feel it
because there's gonna be moments when
she's 14 15 and 16 that your body
remembers what you went through
yeah oh my gosh yeah it remembers and so
yeah that gap you feel that uh you're
that no or that guy's gonna show up to
the house and you're gonna be like you
get that guy at it you know what i mean
those kind of things will happen and
she's gonna think it's already happened
i know and she's gonna think it's her
and i want her to know she actually says
why don't you trust me like what have i
done
to show you that you can't trust me and
i'm like
it's not about you it's about other
people
yeah
no it's only about me and he's my
husband says that i think it's time i
think it's time i mean you're all going
to blow up your 14 year old girl's
little little precious world
oh my goodness she has a therapy she
goes she has a therapist she goes well
yeah here we go right but i think i
think a season of honesty and truth
telling and storytelling is is important
and letting her know she's got her story
and i'll i'll end this call with this um
i i think i may have talked about this
on the show
um i was at an event and doing a q a
there's a thousand people out there
somebody came up and said i realize i've
put a lot of bricks in my kid's backpack
how do i help him get it out
and
i told him you can't
when a brickpick brick goes into
somebody's backpack whether it's trauma
whether it's a story they were told
whether it was a story they were born
into about faith or religion or
exercise or how we eat whatever the
story is
about what you're worth what men and
women do all this stuff
once a brick goes in their backpack
that's their journey that's their
adventure once it's in it doesn't it
doesn't come in i mean then you're not
getting it out that's their job that's
their adventure so the goal for a parent
is to put as few bricks in a kid's
backpack because the world's gonna dump
a bunch of them in there a bunch and
kids are gonna do stupid stuff all
adults we're gonna do dumb things we're
gonna not tell our kids a story for 14
years and now we got to do it that's her
adventure now
that's her adventure
she will come to see both of you as man
that was hard i was honest and you all
were two kids figuring out life and i'm
great fill in the blank and there will
be some pain there that's part of being
a parent part of kids
but once the brick goes in that's theirs
and so how few bricks can we put in our
kids backpack that ends up being the
journey but carmen i'm grateful for the
call
man it's awesome to talk to a woman
who's married to a great guy loves her
husband he's got great kids and is
working hard to do right by your kids
and by the way
you're redeeming your childhood
you went through
hell and you are doing the redemptive
work and you've got the scars to prove
it and your daughter's gonna have a
different life because of the work you
and your husband put in i'm grateful for
you that's awesome
it's awesome